être paysan sur dix ans est actuellement
célibataire alors qu'en moyenne deux
français sur dix ne passe pas devant
monsieur le maire
ces chiffres viennent d'être publiés par
la revue population il montre une
sérieuse augmentation du célibat dans
nos campagnes une situation qui a de
sérieuses répercussions sur la gestion
des entreprises agricoles mais aussi sur
la psychologie des agriculteurs des
exemples eh bien nous en avons trouvé
dans un certain nombre de fermes de la
région de clermont-ferrand
[Musique]
problème de chez les ballons comme pas
hésité
surtout pour les hommes des femmes et
pourquoi - les femmes c'est à dire les
femmes vont se marier à lille c'est la
vie est plus agréable si chez nous une
femme et que vous voulez une famille
elle travaille comme un homme faut
qu'elle est d'aller table il faut
qu'elle sache en plus de celles ci ou
quelle façon ménage encore l'été vous
donne un coup de main en ciel dans ce
que vous voulez faire
on a assisté immédiatement après la
guerre de 14-18 à une course effrénée de
la jeune fille vers la ville
certainement que la femme de paysans
étaient un peu sujette à ce qu'on béton
vers la terre elle était un peu parfois
le domestique
l'exode rural en auvergne d'abord été
celui des femmes l'homme considéré comme
plus important pour le maintien de
l'exploitation agricole et par qui plus
tard et moins souvent vers la ville
résultat aujourd'hui dans le campagne il
y à deux fois et demie plus d'hommes
célibataires qu'en france en général
[Musique]
ce développement du célibat contre un an
surtout développée parmi les petits
paysans pauvres beaucoup moins parmi les
paysans riches et pour quelle raison du
travail ne gagne pas assez alors vous
vous l'avez jamais pu vous marier à
cause de ça vous avez quel âge voyez 60
ans passés
[Musique]
et alors vous avez vécu toute votre vie
sans femme ça vous a pas posé de
problème et il se pose bien des
problèmes
obligés de se débrouiller comme on peut
[Musique]
cet homme vit seule avec son frère et
pour quelle raison parce qu'il faut être
deux c'est à dire qu'il n'y avait pas
trouvé de femmes bien sûr
pourquoi n'y a pas de femmes dans la
région mais ce qu'elles veulent pas
faire râler parmi les générations
d'agriculteurs plus jeunes
le célibat bien qu'un peu moins répandu
persiste encore très largement les
mentalités s'adapte
[Musique]
je crois que le fait de dates en
célibataire de rester célibataire c'est
pas une tellement une fatalité du jury
c'est un concours de circonstances qui
font que on est accaparé ici ou là et
peut-être qu'on est intéressé par une
certaine vie et qu'on se plaît dans
cette vie et donc on reste célibataire
tous ceux qui ont leurs parents
célibataires qui a encore leurs pareils
reste ici d'autres quand les parents
font partie aussi ne sais pas mais en
attendant ils sont là je pense pas que
le fait d'être célibataire soient liés
uniquement au métier d'agriculteur
mais aujourd'hui si une occasion se
présentait vous ne seriez pas opposée au
mariage peut-être au contraire on n'est
jamais reposé en mariage disant que le
marais est le le célibat en lacets pts
parce qu'à un certain moment là
voulurent telles que alors la cep dont
on ne peut pas être opposé au mariage à
moins d'être dans des camps je dirais
dans des des vocations bien spéciale
le célibat diminué aujourd'hui parmi les
jeunes ruraux
c'est surtout parce que depuis 1950 les
hommes jeunes à leur tour quittent
massivement la campagne refusant la
perspective d'être un petit moyens
paysans célibataire en fait cette
diminution du célibat rural notamment en
zone de montagne est l'un des aspects de
la disparition de l'ancienne petite
paysannerie française
[Musique]